on this episode I talk yak-yak
historical figures and what my kids have
taught me you ask questions and I answer
them this is the askgaryvee show
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode number 64 before we get into the
questions today I'm excited we did one
yesterday right oh no the snow day
well I'm snow the fake snow day in
pewter city that really pissed me off
but got some time with the kids which
made it pretty awesome appreciate
everybody I see that Alex DeSimone
where's Alex and is sending his desk
that's why you can't leave Mr Bond give
him big gaps last night his hustle was
strong more people are segwaying into
asking questions on instagram let's link
that up if you want to ask a question on
the show I'm enjoying this this room is
really fascinating to me
betting hard on it all of you
entrepreneurs should it is the number
one social network as the attention
graph goes by the way I need to
desperately make an attention graph like
like we got to get into like that
because that's what I care about let's
get into the show
Austin asks Gary in episode 63 you say
you watch and can tell if people are
hustling how do you tell engagement
frequency or gut also this is a great
question I love the recall to that long
long long time ago episode number 63
yeah I mean this is how I do it and
funny I'm I'm in love with this answer
and like you know 20 I by the way I'm
giving you a a pre alert that I think
the answers on this show are gonna be
really good I feel up for today's answer
I'm gonna go even deeper I remember why
I started this show which is can I go
deeper on all my quotes for my fans I'm
gonna challenge myself in this episode
to go deeper both in the tactical
aspects and the theoretical aspects and
what I mean by that cloud and dirt by
the way what I mean by that is how do I
figure that out is very simple it starts
with the fact that I put in work so when
I go look at your Twitter account and
your Instagram account I will actually
click your posts I will actually look at
all your posts I go to everybody's if
you go to a Twitter account you can hit
their profile and then you can save you
all with replies right so if you go my
account twitter.com slash Gary Vee
you'll see all my non reply tweets I'm
like oh Gary's pushing out a lot of
stuff but if you click with replies all
of a sudden you get
deeper picture into what I'm actually
doing on Twitter which is I'm engaging
at scale with my community so when I get
pissed at all of you one of things I'm
looking at it I'm like oh look at all
these 15 people that I just got the last
35 minutes looking at when I click their
Twitter account because they just engage
with me I'm double checking so I just
click very quickly usually on my phone
okay cool you say hello I mean let's do
one right now real time baby let's do
one right now very simple this is gonna
be interesting
somebody's about to get really called
out right so you open a Twitter app
right and I go to my notifications and I
don't know what I'm gonna get here do
you rock do your best but I'll look and
I'll be like you know social media to
Twitter right well you know social media
twtr this dude right he says he's been I
asked how long have you been following
me a lot of you answered thank you by
the way right so I'll click in and I'll
look at him and I'll say okay a thousand
ten eighty and then I'll look at what
he's actually doing and I see does a lot
of retweeting okay that's interesting to
me right he's doing a ton of retweeting
cuz that's for his account so that gives
me a sense of what he's doing I'm gonna
skip ahead cuz he's kind of playing that
game now Kristin will say great point by
Gary V thanks Kristin and I'll go into
here I'll CCS 7,000 followers they'll
give me some information and then I
start looking at what she's doing and
then she's engaging she's engaging she's
engaging he or she's retweeting she's
hitting that person up I love this hey
saying to somebody they love the new
profile [ __ ] this is starting to give
me a sense and actually Christine let's
give her some let's give her some DAPs
can you zoom in top right corner are you
able to do something there to give her
some DAP so she gets some pink Club yeah
you know so she's doing a good solid
amount of engaging she's doing some nice
solid retweeting she's actually really
engaging oh crap like I don't know I
didn't want to curse there if you look
now go over here D rocket this is very
faint but you can see they're gonna
bring it up shore on the all the way on
the right we're just one hour one hour
two hours can you see that on the right
here it's very small but what I'm seeing
is that she's I mean this is all
happening in the last two hours a lot
heavy engagement she's crushing the
engagement there so then the next thing
I'll do when this is work like like if
anybody understands like like how do i
how do I know cuz I'm putting in the
work next thing I do is I hit her URL on
our Twitter account which is radical dot
social right and then this pops up and
now I'm looking at this this is her blog
as is where she works I don't know yet
but here we're about to look okay
now I'm looking and I'm like do you know
there are tons and I'm like what is this
I'm trying to figure it out and
sometimes if I don't figure it out
quickly I'm like I don't know what this
is I'm out looks like your blog like
talked to me like you know like this is
hitting up Chris anyway so these are the
things I'm doing I'm analyzing right I'm
looking at the other thing to do if I
was looking at my Instagram I look at
the pictures what does that person put
out and what I'm seeing my friends and
the reason I called out so many people
is one I'm seeing the far majority
people only in the right-hook business
right thanks to Christine here I'm in a
good mood because she's jabbing the [ __ ]
out of it right so that's great but then
there's other things is she throwing
right hooks is she trying to drive
people like cuz the right hook is part
of the Jab Jab Jab right hook which is
the overall thesis put out great content
create value upfront convert it into
business and so when I see people and I
see a lot of you asking the same
questions about your coffee business
your catering business all this I'm
trying to see if you're doing that mix
are you only right hooking are you only
jabbing are you driving people
successfully is your is your website
responsive because it's a mobile world
these are like I do this like as you can
see that alone I'm not even done with
Christine like auditing that alone is
five seven nine minutes that's insanity
in a world where I'm so busy but that is
the reason so many of you follow me I
truly believe that I believe in this
karma Zen kind of aspect to it that I'm
capable of giving great answers on this
show cuz I know you way better than you
think
in a world where every one of my
contemporaries that's at my level
whatever that is thinks that the last
three minutes of this show the things
that I do with my time in a world where
in my inbox I mean let's let's let's
break this down let's understand what
I'm talking about in a world where I've
got all these emails right now and like
going back and so I hope some of my
clients are gonna get upset here I think
but like here's a very important email
from John the lead developer at Wine
Library about a new program that we're
about to launch on wine lobby to come
from Friday not answered yet right
because I'm looking at Christine's
Twitter account nobody no businessperson
thinks that's the right move none and so
I think if you want to pop if you want
to be an anomaly you've got to act like
one Andre asks
Gary I'm interested in your thoughts
about marketing opportunities on Yik yak
Andre so this is a great question
back to the attention graph that I just
hold in here that we need to drill on
the biggest reason that I'm talking
about yet yak so much is it does have
the overwhelming attention at scale of
this kind of 18 to 22 year old demo
that's on college campuses the truth is
I'm not really prepared to answer this
question that's why I took it the truth
is I haven't put in enough work on yet
yak it's here right it's here but look
look what do you kick is right I know
d-roc you're doing a lot of like I'm
sorry but this is important this is
another insight some of the stuff I do
it's why I grab so many people's phones
right look what are you kick is as you
can see socials really jamming here
right but you can extend this little
folder it says social and it's not even
on the first one it's here so clearly
are you laughing cuz you're not getting
a good zoom oh it's hiding that's right
the rocket is hiding and so so even
though I'm talking a big game about my
belief in the attack my actions aren't
following my words right now I'm doing a
bad job of not being the best expert at
Yik yak I haven't spent a lot of time in
there obviously the kind of anonymous
commenting you know how do you get away
with like promoting your burger joint or
a pizza shop or wine library you have to
21 and 22 year old you kick users like
what do you do like do you ask a
question about your own business or do
you make a statement about your own
business that's a little spammy that you
know the problem with the IKEA as a
marketing platform right now is it's
like the old forums back in the day when
everybody was anonymous in 90s and I
would go to like wine spectator's wine
bulletin board and be like wine library
is an amazing store in town it you know
you don't know how to do it right right
like I guess in theory you can make a
comment of like I hear that the Johnny
burgers own cook is really hot hahaha
because it's me like I guess there's a
way if you're very authentic you can win
that game and there's clearly ways to
market unfortunately the thing I make
fun of so many of you of and so many
people love which is you're not a
practitioner you're reading headlines I
unfortunately this situation and a lack
of a practitioner and you do a little
bit more my work as you can tell I have
enough dangerous knowledge of giving you
an example of some of them
things you can do but you know the
question will become what will you yak
allow brands to do if anything but
clearly let's if you have a restaurant
or hangout in the college demo right now
and you're not desperately trying to
figure out you yak every minute you're
making a huge mistake coach asks Gary we
spend all of our time pouring our
creativity into projects for our clients
so that when it's time to shift gears
and focus on our brand we're exhausted
how do you keep it burning for both
coach this simple answer here is very
simply that you need to you need to work
harder and faster there's really nothing
else I mean how do I I'm exhausted every
day but I'm making enormous amounts of
things happen in my 18 hours right not
only am i working 18 hours but I'm
working fast as hell in those 18 hours
and I'm prioritizing what's important
what's not and so you know I guess the
end the answer to your question is we're
all different I mean if you need to be a
type and rigor and organized I would
just schedule non-negotiable time for
your personal brand if that's important
to you from 6 to 7 p.m. because you have
that whole day to like kind of check the
box that you want to and you just got
that time it's just allocated maybe that
time is a 10 to midnight but really
there's no magic answer here the answer
is more time and faster within that time
I think the faster part confuses a lot
of people right I always talk about like
stop watching lost sleep less but
there's another variable be much faster
in the hours that you're actually in
like these guys can tell you there is
not a second that's down a little when
people like I work 10 hours a day and
then when I oughta them there was like
15 minutes here where they watched a
YouTube video like I mean like just
ludecke like every second like we fight
for minutes here we fight for seconds
here I wish there was other cameras
showing you how hard the bobbleheads are
on the crew here every minute and so
like my gut is because I when I thought
I was the biggest workaholic that ever
lived
from 22 to 30 and running Wine Library
but I had enough time to [ __ ] about
baseball with Brandon for nine minutes
or talk to my dad about something 4:15
that made no sense and didn't matter
or went to espn.com to just check jet
score like I had time I had time
I'm dramatically faster at 39 that I was
a 29 and I'm working more hours that's
how it's happening I know the answer I
lived it I I am making fun of 29 year
old Gary Vee for all the spewing that I
do that dude wasn't as fast and didn't
go for as long every day and that's just
how I've done it Ben asks Gary what if
your children taught you about life and
business first of all that was a great
video Big Ups I think the Instagram
videos have huge potential as well the
creativity is coming through more than
the YouTube videos were just person
space so that's a lot of fun you know
it's funny I took that this question as
well because I think my answer is gonna
be super unpopular I think I think a lot
of people are gonna be you know
everybody's looking for the romantic
answer right like you know the truth is
I love my kids insanely but I love my
wife and I love my parents so insanely
that you know I love them more
but like the rocks I'll be scared when I
go politically incorrect no do you rock
you Minister true that I promise to be
very honest on this like do I love my
kids more to my parents it's a really
interesting debate for me it's much
closer than the normal politically
correct or answer that I hear from
others so it's not like they taught me
how to love I hate you know people say
that all time I was [ __ ] loving
everything before but I guess some you
know I guess at the end of the day the
things that really really you know what
this is the tree answer the the thing
that my kids have taught me about life
and I guess I believe this very much in
business and so many of you that have
been jamming with me for a long time
know they've taught me from the other
side how powerful DNA really is watching
my kids do the same exact things I do
like Misha when she performs in our
living room
she's spending more time trying to pay
attention if we're paying attention then
on her actual performance that's what I
do when I give talks I'm like looking in
the crowd to make sure they're not on
their phone like you know Xander's looks
of like like I got you like just crazy
so like they've taught me how powerful
DNA is it's you know and maybe they
taught me too
you know maybe they've taught me a more
extreme level of respect for Lizzie I'm
it saying she's an just an incredible
mother and just watching how she's
executing in her role with them is is uh
has taught me a lot about her but for me
you know they haven't taught me jack
crap about business and other than the
reason I bet on people is based on my
intuition around their DNA and then I
watched their DNA come full-throttle
I'm just a big DNA guy Lex asks Gary
I've got a question for you who is the
historical figure you would have lunch
with if you could and why Lex great
question first and foremost two things
one Lex I really think you should put a
URL in your Instagram account so links
out and to vaynernation you should check
out his Instagram
it is a tremendous tremendous effort
great pictures
I mean we're rolling with heavy truth in
episode 64 the answer to this question
is nobody and I really really really
hate giving it because if I'm on the
other side of this camera I'm looking at
that and saying you think you're so
great that there's nobody you want to
meet and weirdly there's probably a
truth to that it is actually
fundamentally completely insane how
little energy I have of meeting anybody
all time
there's plenty people that I find
ridiculously fascinating you know
Winston Churchill is super high and
interesting Randy the Macho Man Savage
is a big one for me Pete Rozelle the
former NFL Commissioner I just read his
book I don't read a lot of books I read
a book when me and Lizzy went away in
November I'm up to nine you know there's
a million wall you know Walt Disney's
interesting storytelling like there's
people interesting but it's crazy like
if you said you could have dinner with
any historical figure we're talking
Abraham Lincoln Walt Disney or the Jets
could be you could be not playing in the
Super Bowl that's what I'm going you
could be in August right now and
watching the Jets first preseason game
I'd rather do the Jets preseason game
think about how
insane that is like pre-season I said
it's there's something really broken
with me and I think it comes from ego
DNA I do or it just speaks to like a
theme that I think a lot of you know
which is I'm like this right like I'm um
I mean I you know I'd rather look at
christine's Twitter account for 19
minutes and bring that value to the
people that have bestowed in me the
interest and paying attention to me then
for me to go and spend you know a nice
meal and drink some nice wine with you
know Joseph Stalin so I could tell him
he was a piece of crap I mean I don't
know like like I don't I don't I don't
uh I don't feel it I've never felt it I
have no interest it's just super not
interesting for me question of the day
which historic figure would you like to
have dinner with you keep asking me
questions
Oh keep
[Music]